a popular Beachside Hotel on mogadishu's
Coastline used by many visitors and
politicians Friday evenings are usually
for families to enjoy a night out but
that all changed when al-shabab Fighters
stormed this hotel on Lido Beach
Witnesses say they heard gunfire and
explosions many tried to flee
we saw a big disaster here at Lido Beach
at updates District I was having fun
with my friend as soon as the first
Blood struck the area I saw one lady
falling to the ground she was hit by the
shrapnel from the explosion
to an hour's long gun battle police say
it ended at midnight local time with all
seven al-shabab Fighters killed people
who were inside the hotel at the time of
the attack described the chaotic moments
that followed
I was sitting near the beach when the
first explosion happened at the front
gate of the hotel and there was another
one at the back I ran to a wall nearby
and hid myself behind it and Somali
forces rescued me from there
the attack killed several people and
injured many more
the number of casualties may actually be
much higher because there were other
ambulances operating as well as private
Vehicles who were able to collect
victims of the attack
ultrabob has largely been driven out of
somalia's towns and cities but it's
still active in rural areas its Fighters
often Target high-profile locations like
hotels in the capital
the government says it's doing what it
can to stop attacks like these but for
many people who live in the city and
have seen Decades of conflict they're
left wondering when all the Bloodshed
will stop rahila Muhammad al-jazeera
absolutely